giải mã trên phần 203
netizen thắc mắc Aura của bản thân có màu gì
không biết làm SAO để xác định hào quang của bản thân
phải có năng lực tâm linh mới nhìn thấy
mới đây từ khóa hào quang
Aura đang được giới trẻ tìm kiếm nhiều nhất
bởi sự độc lạ của nó
nhiều người tìm Ra bản thân mình có Aura khác nhau
không AI giống AI
nhưng nhiều cư dân mận vẫn không biết làm cách nào có
thể biết chính xác bản thân có màu gì
hay phải có năng lực tâm linh mới có thể làm được
sau đây là cách bạn có thể nhìn thấy Aura của mình
bước một
chọn một không gian thoải mái cùng tâm trạng thoải mái
với ánh sáng mờ
nhưng không quá tối mù mít
bước 2 bạn tập trung vào một điểm 3060 giây
đưa bàn Tay của bạn lên trên một bức tường trắng
lay nhẹ hoặc chạm các ngón Tay với nhau
bước BA tập trung khu vực giữa 2 ngón Tay
năng lượng Aura sẽ ở đó
càng luyện tập hào quang sẽ càng rõ ràng và dễ thấy
khi đó hãy luyện tập với cả bàn Tay
xoa 2 Tay với nhau và tách Ra để thấy hào quang ở giữa